The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at MIT.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to this
lecture on non-linear finite
element analysis of solids and
structures.
In this lecture, I'd like to
continue with our discussion
of structural elements, and
in particular, I'd like to
concentrate our attention first
on the formulation of
beam elements.
After that, I'd like to talk
more about the formulation of
shell elements, and then
show you applications.
When we talk about beam
elements, we might think about
the usual Hermitian beam
elements, in which the
transverse placements cubically
interpolated, and
the longitudinal displacements
are linearly interpolated.
This is an element that is
usually used in linear
analysis, and very
widely used--
you might have used it quite
a bit yourself--
and it is also very effective
in the analysis of linear
response of structures.
However, in my discussion now,
I will talk about the
isoparametric beam element,
and how we formulate the
isoparametric beam element, in
other words, and how we apply
it in the analysis
of structures.
So when I talk about the beam
element, I really mean this
isoparametric beam element that
we are formulating in
this lecture.
The isoparametric beam
formulation can be very
effective for the analysis of
curve themes, for the analysis
of geometrically nonlinear
problems, and for the analysis
of stiffened shell structures,
where we couple the
isoparametric beam with the
isoparametrically formulated
shell elements.
The formulation is quite
analogous to the formulation
of the isoparametric degenerate
shell elements that
we discussed in the previous
lecture, and so we can go a
bit fast over the formulation
of the beam element here.
I'm showing a typical
beam element,
rectangular cross section.
Here we show three nodes.
Actually, the beam element can
be used with two nodes, three
nodes, or four nodes, as we will
discuss further later on.
We notice that the depth off
the element is ak, the
thickness of the
element is bk.
And notice that at these nodes,
we measure certain
nodal point variables.
and here I'm showing the nodal
point variables that we do
measure at the nodes.
Three displacements, incremental
displacements, and
three incremental rotations.
Notice that the description of
the beam element follows much
the same as the geometric
description of the beam
element follows, much the same
way as we are dealing with the
shell element.
We introduce director vectors.
Now we have two director
vectors.
In the shell, of course,
we had only one
director vector per node.
Now we have two.
Here we show tvsk, the director
vector at time t into
the S-direction, corresponding
to node k.
Notice here tvtk.
The director vector at time t
corresponding to node k into
the t direction.
this t means direction t that
t opting out means time t
Notice that corresponding to
this direction t here, we have
the t isoparametric
coordinate.
And of course, this t
isoparametric coordinate also
runs into the thickness ak.
Notice that corresponding to
bk, we have the s-direction
coordinate, and that s-direction
coordinate,
s-isoparametric coordinate, runs
into the direction of the
director vector, tvsk.
So these are the variables used
to describe the geometry
and the displacement of
the beam element.
We start with the general
equation for the
geometry at time t.
Here we have txi.
The coordinates of a material
particle within the
element at time t--
and remember, these are the
coordinates measured in the
stationary coordinate system.
And these coordinates are
obtained as shown on the
right-hand side.
Let's have a close look
at what we see on
the right-hand side.
We have the hk interpolation
function.
This is the interpolation
function corresponding to the
r-direction running through
the nodes of the element,
along the mid-surface
of the element.
And it's a one-dimensional
interpolation function, the
same one that we used to see
for the truss element.
These are the nodal point
coordinates at time t.
We are summing over all the
nodal points, k from 1 to n,
and n can be equal to 2, 3, or
4, as I mentioned earlier.
Then we add to this term a term
that comes in because of
the sickness of the beam into
the t-direction, ak, thickness
off the beam into the
t-direction--
here is a t-coordinate.
The isoparametric coordinates
going from minus 1 to plus 1.
Here we have hk, same
interpolation function as
there, and here we have the
direction, cosines of the
director vector in the
t-direction at time t.
A similar term, similar to this
one, is added for the
f-direction.
s, the isoparametric coordinate,
running from minus
1 to plus 1, bk being the
thickness into the s-direction
at node k, hk, same
interpolation function that we
have seen up here already, and
these are the direction
cosines of the director vector
in the s-direction,
corresponding to node
k at time t.
This equation is very similar
to the equation that we used
in the shell element
formation.
Of course, in the shell element
formulation, we
interpolated here in a
two-dimensional domain over
the shell mid-surface.
Now we only run along the
neutral axis of the beam.
And we had only one term in the
shell corresponding to the
director vector.
There was only one direction,
namely, the one normal to the
mid-surface of the shell.
Here we have two directions
to deal with.
Since the displacements can
directly be obtained from the
geometry interpolation at time
t minus the geometry
interpolation at time 0,
of course this geometry
interpolation is obtained by
simply substituting in the
equation that we just looked
at for time t, the time 0.
Since we obtain tui, as shown
here, this is the result.
We simply apply our geometry
interpolation at time t, and
at time 0, subtract.
This is what you get on
the right-hand side.
Nodal point displacement from
time 0 to time t, measured in
the stationary global Cartesian
coordinate system.
Here change in the director
vector cosines, or I should
say, more precisely maybe, the
change in the cosine of the
angle director vector time 0,
director vector time t.
Of course, remember here we
have direction cosines
corresponding to time t.
Here we have direction cosines
corresponding to time 0.
We subtract, and that
goes in here.
Here, same kind of term,
but for direction s.
Also the incremental
displacements are obtained
from this relationship here, and
if you apply the geometry
interpolation at time t plus
delta t and at time t, you
directly obtain this
right-hand side.
These are the increment in the
direction cosine from time t
to time t plus delta t of the
director vector in the
t-direction.
Similar here for the
s-direction.
Of course, we are used very well
to deal with increment
and nodal point displacement,
but we cannot very well deal
with these quantities
here, vti and vsi.
We want to deal with nodal
point rotation.
And so what we do is, we express
this quantity and that
quantity in terms of nodal
point rotations, and that
those expressions are
given down here.
These are the two expressions.
You can simply multiply out, and
you would immediately see
that they indeed hold.
With these geometry and
displacement interpolations
established, we can now
directly calculate or
establish the strain
displacement matrices
corresponding to the Cartesian
strain components, and then a
simple transformation, standard
transformation gives
us the strain displacement
matrices corresponding to the
eta zeta psi directions.
Of course, these are the
directions with the components
of strains and stresses that we
need to deal with for the
beam formulation.
Notice that zeta here is a
physical coordinate running
into the direction, so to say,
of the a thickness of the
beam, and zeta corresponds to
the t-isoparametric coordinate
that we just talked about.
Psi here corresponds to the
s-isoparametric coordinate,
and runs into the b width,
so to say, of the beam.
Eta here corresponds to the
r-isoparametric coordinate.
Of course, these zeta, eta, and
psi are actual physical
coordinates that we
are dealing with.
We have to, of course, calculate
the tau psi eta, the
tau eta eta, and the tau vita
psi stress components and
corresponding strain components
for the beam
formulation.
And the stress-strain law,
corresponding to these
components, is given here.
Notice tau eta eta is obtained
by taking the Young's modulus
and multiplying the Young's
modulus by epsilon
eta eta, and so on.
Notice here we have one share
component and another share
component corresponding to this
column and corresponding
to that column, and here we
have k factor, the share
correction factor, that we
already used from the shell
analysis formulation that
we discussed earlier.
Notice that via the same
approach, we can also directly
obtain a beam element for
elastoplastic and creep analysis.
In this particular case, of
course, the only stress
component that would be non-zero
again would be tau
eta eta, tau eta zeta,
and tau eta psi.
The approach here is very
similar to what we have
discussed earlier regarding the
shell element formation.
There is one important point
in the beam element
formulation.
Namely that with the kinematic
assumptions used so far for
the beam element, we do not
allow cross-sectional
out-of-plane displacement.
We do not allow warping.
Our interpolation does not
contain the effect of warping.
In torsion or loading, however,
we know that warping
is very important, and for that
reason, we need to amend
our displacement assumptions
by two or more displacement
patterns, so to say.
We allow these displacements to
take place in the element.
u eta is equal to alpha
times psi beta.
This is the exact warping
displacement for infinitely
narrow sections.
And this term here, with beta
a constant, is the exact
warping displacement for
a square cross section.
Now the actual section might
not be infinitely narrow,
might not be square, but we can
easily test, and I will
show you just now an example
of that in fact, a
superposition of these functions
and the evaluation
of alpha and beta by static
condensation actually yields
good results, even for
cross-sections that are not
infinitely narrow, and that
are not exactly square.
Let's look at an example,
linear elasticity.
If we take a section and simply
put it into torsion
with b/a equal to 1, the
analytical value given by
Timoshenko for this k constant
here in that formula is 0.141.
And we obtain with
this formulation
exactly that same value.
We need to get it, because we
have embedded the proper
interpolation for u eta into
our formulation, and then u
static condensation, of course,
to condense out these
two constants, alpha and beta,
that I just talked about.
For b/a, a very large, very
narrow section, we also get
the exact result in our finite
element solution, the exact
analytical result.
In between, we have a small
arrow, an arrow that, however,
we believe is quite
acceptable.
Let's look at one example that
I'd like to show you the
results of.
You might be interested
in this example.
Here we have a narrow ring.
Here you have a plan view of
that ring with the dimensions
given, and Young's modulus and
Poisson's ratio given for that
ring, subject to these
bending moments.
Of course, the twisting
capability or capacity of the
beam is of utmost importance
now, has to be properly
modelled under this
loading condition.
The model that we use
to analyze the
problem is shown here.
And you can see, at one side of
the ring, we have fixed it,
and at the other side,
we prescribed a
rotation, see eta x.
We use here four node
elements as shown.
This analysis was actually
inspired by us looking around
in our office and seeing a
magnetic tape lying there.
And if you look around, you
might have yourself a magnetic
tape there.
And you pick up this little ring
from the magnetic tape.
And here I'd like to just
demonstrate to you briefly
what we are doing.
You see here, we have this ring,
much alike of what I've
shown you on the view graph.
I'm fixing it on the one side,
and on my right hand now,
these two fingers, I'm going
to put a rotation onto that
ring, and I'm going to turn
my fingers 180 degrees.
So please watch closely.
This is what I'm doing.
I'm just turning my fingers
180 degrees.
And by turning my fingers 180
degrees, if you watch very
closely, you can see that the
top of the ring does not touch
the bottom of the ring.
There is actually a little gap
in between, of course, because
of the elasticity in the ring.
So this is what I've tried to
do now on the computer.
And what I'm particularly
interested to see is the
amount of moment required in my
right hand, so to say, to
be transmitted to the ring
in order to twist it.
Well, here we have the results
for the computer solution.
Notice here, we have a force
deflection, curve, rotation
here, up to 180 degrees.
Moment plotted here
in pounds, inch.
And you can see that there's
fairly linear behavior first,
but then a highly non-linear
behavior as the rotation
becomes very large.
Here we use the TL formulation
for the beam element.
And once again, we rotated it
180 degrees, as I have shown
you with my little
experiment here.
If you look at the beam, you see
a top view like that, and
the side view looks this way.
I've pointed out that
top and bottom do
not touch each other.
There's a little air
gap in between.
I'd like to show you now another
solution regarding the
torsion in an analysis.
And let me walk over to the
slides here, where I actually
have two slides regarding
that solution.
The interesting part of this
problem is that we now, in
this particular analysis, are
using the same displacement
interpolation functions for
which I've shown you already--
two analyses in which the
material remained elastic.
The same interpolation functions
are now also used to
analyze an elastoplastic
problem.
And the problem is described
here, where we have now a
square section subjected
to a torque.
The material data that Greenberg
used are given here.
And in our analysis, we used
this material data, where the
yield stress and the
strain-hardening modulus are
matched to this stress-strain
law here.
Now notice what is going to
happen is, we are increasing
this torque incrementally, and
we want to bring, of course,
this section into the
elastoplastic regime to see
how the section will
take the torque.
On this slide now, we have
plotted the torque vertically
and the rotation horizontally,
both quantities with some
constants attached,
as you can see.
And the Greenberg result and
the Adina result are indeed
very close.
Please look at the reference
that is given in the study
guide if you're interested in
seeing and reading more about
this problem.
Let me now walk back to the view
graph and continue with
the discussion of the material
relating to isoparametric
beams and shell elements.
The next topic that I like to
talk to you about is the
actual use of these elements.
Of course, the shell element
that I'm here talking about,
or that I will share some more
experiences with you upon, is
the shell element that I have
been already discussing in the
earlier lecture.
So please refer back to that
lecture with respect to this
discussion.
One interesting point is that
these elements can all be
programmed for use with
different numbers of nodes.
For the beam, we can have two,
three, or four nodes, as
already mentioned earlier, and
for the shell, we could have
4, 8, 9, up to 16 nodes,
as I mentioned also
in the earlier lecture.
The elements with these nodal
point configurations can be
employed for analysis of
moderately thick structures.
Remember, shear deformations
are
approximately taken into account.
However, if the sink of the
analysis of thin structures,
then we have to be very careful,
and only certain
elements of the ones that
I just referred
to should be employed.
For shells, we can only
recommend to use a 16-node
element with 4-by-4 Gauss
integration over the
mid-surface.
This element is depicted here.
1, 2, 3, 4, 4 times gives
us 16 nodes, and 4-by-4
integration indicated
by the blue crosses.
For beams, we'd best use the
2-node beam element with
1-point integration along the
r-direction, or the 3-node
beam element with 2-point
integration along the
r-direction, all or with Gauss
integration, or the 4-node
beam element with 3-point Gauss
integration along the
r-direction.
We have to ask, of course,
now, why is that so?
Well, the reason is that the
other elements become overly
and artificially stiff when we
use them to model thin and
curved structures.
Two phenomena occur--
shear locking and membrane
locking.
Most interesting phenomena.
And I'd like to share with you
now some information regarding
these phenomena.
The 2-, 3-, and 4-node beam
elements with 1-, 2-, and
3-point Gauss integration along
the beam axes do not
display these phenomena,
these shear- and
membrane-locking phenomena.
But please notice, I'm using
1-, 2-, and 3-point Gauss
integration corresponding
to the 2-, 3-,
and 4-node beam element.
The 16-node element with 4-by-4
integration, Gauss
integration, is also relatively
immune to shear and
membrane locking.
However, we have to
be careful here.
The element should not be
distorted for best predictive
capability.
Let us study what this shear
locking phenomenon is.
And to do so, let us look at a
2-noded beam, a very simple
beam, in just 2-dimensional
action.
So we have one node here and
one node here, and the
defomations of the beam are
described by w1 and theta 1 at
this node, and w2 and theta
2 at this node.
Notice the deformations of the
beam, of course, are given by
w, the transverse displacement,
and beta, the
section rotation.
The transverse displacement and
section rotation, w and
beta, are interpolated linearly,
as shown here, via
the nodal point displacements
and rotations.
Notice the linear interpolation,
of course, is
given here via this expression
and that expression, and
similarly here via this
expression and that
expression.
Now there's one important point,
namely that w and beta
are independent quantities.
If you are familiar, as
you probably are, with
Euler-Bernoulli beam theory,
you recognize that in
they are not independent
quantities.
In fact, beta is dw dr, or dw
dx, x being the physical
coordinate.
Here in our formation,
isoparametric degenerate
element, we have that beta and
w, these two quantities, once
again, are independent and
linearly interpolated in this
particular beam element.
Of course, these two quantities
are tied together
by the physics, and that is
by the shear deformation.
So let's look at that next.
Here we have that gamma shear
strain is equal to a del w del
x minus beta.
And this is shown here
on the picture.
Notice this is a neutral axis of
the beam, which originally
of course was horizontal.
Here we have a vertical line
shown in green, and the
section rotation is shown
at the angle beta here.
These are the material particles
shown in red that
were originally, of course, at
right angles to the neutral
axes, and that were originally
lying vertically up.
In other words, this line here,
this red line was a
vertical line originally, and
was originally at right angles
to the neutral axis.
That right angle is not
preserved because gamma is
there, and gamma is, in
general, a non-zero.
This is here of course dw dx.
So this picture here
shows what we are
calculating up here.
And you can see that gamma
ties together w and beta,
which are, however, by
themselves, interpolated
independently.
Consider now the simple case of
a cantilever subjected to a
tip-bending moment.
And we use one 2-node beam
element to model the
cantilever.
Clearly at this end, the section
rotation is 0, and w1,
the transverse displacement
is also 0.
So these are the bounded
conditions at this end of the
cantilever.
And if we use these bounded
conditions and put them into
our general equation, we get
directly that beta is given as
shown here, and gamma is
given as shown here.
Now look at this equation
carefully.
We have a constant term and
a linear varying term.
The exact solution to this
problem, analytical solution
to this problem, if we use
elementary beam theory, we
would immediately recognize that
the shear strain must be
0 for this element, or for
this beam situation.
The shear strain should be 0.
Now, if we look at this
carefully, we can see that
gamma can only be 0 if w2
is 0, and theta 2 is 0.
But if theta 2 and w2 are 0,
rotation and transverse
displacement right here at this
end, then the beam would
have not deflected.
Of course, that is not
borne out in physics.
We know that if we take a beam
and put a bending moment on
it, then we get a deflection
here and a
rotation at this end.
So you can see already from this
equation here that there
will be some difficulty.
There will be some difficulty
because gamma should be 0
physically, and this equation
tells us that gamma can't
really be exactly 0.
Well, that is once more
summarized in
this sentence here--
clearly, gamma cannot be 0 at
all the points along the beam
unless theta 2 and
w2 are both 0.
But then also beta would be 0,
and there would be no bending
of the beam.
Let's look now at this point.
Since for the beam, the bending
strain energy is
proportional to h cubed,
elementary beam theory again,
the shear strain energy
is proportional to h--
elementary beam theory--
we see immediately that any
arrow in the shear strains due
to the finite element
interpolation functions
becomes increasingly
more detrimental
is h becomes small.
Why is that the case?
If h becomes small, then
this number becomes
very rapidly small.
This number here become small,
but this one goes much faster
to us, very small, so to say.
And if there's an error in the
shear strain energy, that
error, because of this
proportionality sign, is going
to be magnified relative to any
error that we would see
here, and it's going to be
detrimental in our solution.
Let's look at an example.
For the cantilever example, this
very simple example that
we just studied already a bit,
the shear strain energy should
be 0, and as h decreases, the
relative error in the shear
strain increases rapidly, and
in effect introduces an
artificial stiffness which
we identify as
locking of the model.
This is the terminology that
is quite widely used now.
We say that the model locks.
Let's look at some results.
In this table, we show the
results for h/L with L equal
to 100 for these three values.
The analytical value for the
rotation at the end where the
bending moment is applied
is given here.
Bernoulli beam theory.
The finite element solution,
using, of course, exact
integration--
I always assume I should
maybe point that very
strongly still out.
We assume that we use exact
integration of the K matrix.
Meaning in this particular
case, we're using 2-point
Gauss integration along the
length of the beam.
With that scheme then, we obtain
with a h/L being 0.5.
Well, an error, but something
still reasonable.
After all, we're only
using one element.
Of course, we are pretty far
off, but still something
reasonable.
But now notice, as you decrease
h, h/L, of course,
becomes much smaller.
Theta analytical goes up.
The beam basically
bends, is very
flexible as it gets thinner.
And the finite element solution
also becomes more
flexible, gives us a more
flexible beam, but is much too
stiff when compared to the
analytical solution.
Notice for orders of magnitudes
difference.
If you plot it, this is
basically 0 compared to that
value, and that means
the beam locks.
It doesn't really at all
bend anymore as h
becomes very thin.
This behavior is, of course,
also observed when you take
more than 1 element
to model the beam.
Here we show more elements than
just one, and notice that
each of these elements
should still carry a
constant bending moment.
If it cannot do so, it develops,
in other words,
these furious shear strains.
We are going to have a very
stiff model, even when we use
that many elements.
Let's look at this particular
example close off.
And here we have an example
beam, in other words,
cantilever beam, subjected
to the bending moment.
l equals 10 meter.
Square cross section,
height 0.1 meter.
We use the 2-noded beam
elements to model this
cantilever, and we plot the tip
deflection as a function
of the number of elements.
A most interesting graph.
Look, here is the beam
theory solution.
And here we plot the number
of elements--
here we talk about 400 elements,
because there's
times 10 to the 2 down here.
400 elements at this point.
600 elements, 800 elements,
200 elements.
At this point we have
100 elements.
The height of an element
is equal to the
length of the element.
And at this point, we still
don't even get a good
approximation to the beam
theory solution.
We need basically something like
400 to 500, 600 elements
to get close to the beam
theory solution.
However, if we take a very large
number of elements, we
actually do converge, but we
need a lot of elements, as you
can see here.
Of course, it is quite
impractical to use this kind
of 2-noded beam element to model
thin structures, then
beams. Once again, I must point
out that we use 2-point
Gauss integration into the
r-direction, and therefore,
we're dealing with the exact K
matrix corresponding to the
interpolation that we have
embedded into the element.
In fact, if we look in this
regime down here, we find that
as shown on this view graph,
the solution really becomes
beta very slowly as the number
of elements is increased.
Notice that the solution really
doesn't increase in
accuracy much at all as we go
from 10, 20, to 30 elements.
A remedy for the 2-node beam
element is to only use 1-point
integration along
the beam axis.
This then corresponds to
assuming a constant transverse
shear strain.
However, by using 1-point
integration, we still
integrate the bending
strain exactly.
Because remember, beta is
linear, del beta del x is
constant, and 1-point
integration will pick up that
term exactly.
If we look at the results, now
once again, of this problem,
cantilever problem, the
cantilever beam is subjected
to an end moment,
tip end moment.
We find now which h/l, as shown
here, theta analytical,
shown here, and our finite
elements solution with just
one element, using one element,
of course now with
1-point integration in
r-direction, gives us
excellent results.
In fact, the exact results,
as you can see here.
The 3- and 4-note beam elements,
evaluated using 2-
and 3-point integration,
are similarly affected.
In fact, they give us also the
exact results for this problem
that we've considered.
We should note now that these
theme elements, based on what
one might reduced integration,
are actually reliable
elements, because they do not
possess any spurious zero
energy modes.
They have, in other words, only
six zero energy modes
corresponding to the actual
physical rigid body mode that
the elements should contain,
should be able to represent,
in its three-dimensional
space.
So they only have those six zero
eigenvalues in this 3D
analysis that they should have,
and no spurious zero
energy modes.
The formulation can actually
be interpreted as a mixed
interpolation of displacements
and transferred shear strains.
And this is really the key for
developing all the low-order
effective shell elements.
I will get back to that in
just a little while.
So far, we have talked
about shear locking.
I mentioned earlier also that
there is a phenomenon of
membrane-locking.
Membrane-locking means that in
addition to not exhibiting
erroneous shear strains, the
beam model must also not
contain erroneous mid-surface
membrane strains, particularly
when we analyze curved
structures.
The beam elements that I just
mentioned, 2-noded beam with
1-point r-integration, 3-noded
beam with 2-point
r-integration, 4-noded beam with
3-point r-integration, do
also not membrane-lock.
Let's consider here, once again,
a simple example--
a simple curve beam subjected
to a bending moment,
tip-bending moment, fixed
at the other end.
Here is an angle alpha that
the beam spans out.
The exactly integrated 3-noded
beam element, when curved,
does contain erroneous shear
strains and erroneous
mid-surface membrane strains.
In other words, shear locks
and membrane locks.
And that is shown in
this table here, at
least to some extent.
What I can't show is how much
there is shear-locking and how
much there is membrane-locking.
You would see that both effects
are very significant.
If you were to run, for example,
this beam element
with a computer program, using,
for this beam element,
3-point integration into the r
direction and printing out the
stresses, print out all the
stress components and look at
the shear component and the
membrane components, in other
words, the normal stress
components,
along the neutral axes.
If you do so, you would see that
they are very significant
shear stresses and very
significant membrane stresses,
which of course should be
0 for this problem.
And these are, of course,
causing the locking effect.
Here we have the results in
terms of just rotations, h/R
now, with R equal to 100, given
here, analytical value
given here, finite element
solutions, 3-node element with
3-point integration, you can
see we have a locking
phenomenon right here.
Once again, how much there is
membrane, and how much shear
locking you would see by
actually running as a problem
and looking at the
shear stress and
the membrane stress.
And the finite element
solution with 2-point
integration gives excellent
results.
So this is, of course, the
element that we would be using
in engineering practice.
Similarly, we can study
the use of the
4-node cubic beam element.
And here we find that for h/R,
these values, analytical value
once more listed here, we find
that the 4-node element with
4-point integration gives also
very good results, and the
3-point integration gives
also excellent results.
So we note that the cubic beam
element performs well, even
when using full integration.
It is not susceptible to
membrane and shear locking.
But notice, we have our
third-point node exactly at
the third point of
the elements.
Once we start shifting these
nodes, then we would also not
get as good results
as shown here.
We would not get these good
results once you shift the
node at the third point away
from their physical third
point locations.
Now, considering the analysis
of shells, the phenomenon of
shear and membrane locking
are also present, but the
difficulty lies in that this
simple reduced integration
approach that we're using for
the beam elements cannot be
directly applied, because the
resulting elements contain
spurious zero energy modes.
For example, if you integrate
the 4-node shell element just
with 1-point integration,
contains 6 spurious zero
energy modes.
In other words, it has
altogether 12 zero eigenvalues
where it should only have 6.
The 6 of them are
spurious modes.
And such spurious energy modes
can lead to very large errors
in the solution that, unless
we have a comparison with
accurate results, are not known,
and therefore, it can
be very dangerous to
use such elements.
We want to have elements that
are reliable in general
applications, and these elements
should only contain
the actual physical rigid
body modes, no
spurious zero energy modes.
And of course, should also
have high predictive
capability, not have any shear
or membrane locking.
For this reason, we can only
recommend the 16-node shell
element with 4-by-4
Gauss integration.
The cubic beam element result
that I just showed you
regarding the analysis of the
curve beam already indicated
that the cubic element
does quite well.
In fact, that is also
borne out by the
16-node shell element.
Using 4-by-4 Gauss integration
on the shell mid-surface, we
have an element that is
relatively immune to membrane
and shear locking, but I
mentioned already that the
element should not
be distorted.
And if it's not distorted,
it performs best.
I'd just like to share now
with you some thoughts
regarding development that
we have recently pursued.
Namely, recently we have
developed elements based on
the mixed interpolation of
tensorial components.
This sounds very complicated.
Actually, if you look closely at
what we're doing, it is not
that complicated.
The elements, however, do not
lock in shear or membrane
action, and also do not contain
any spurious zero
energy mode.
And of course, that is the key
of success of an element.
We will use later on in the
example solutions a 4-node
element that is based on this
mixed interpolation of
tensorial components.
We call that element the MITC4,
Mixed Interpolation
Tensorial Component with 4 nodes
element, and I want to
discuss this element just
briefly with you now.
We also have developed
an element that
we call MITC8 element.
It's an 8-node element based
on mixed interpolation of
tensorial components.
A most interesting
development.
If you're interested in that
development, please refer to
the paper that is given, or that
is being referred to, in
the study guide.
I'd like to discuss with you
now the MITC4 element, and
then show you example
solutions.
However, we have, in order to be
able to do that, to change
now the reel, so let us just do
so, and then continue with
this discussion.
So let us look then at the MITC4
element briefly, the
element that I mentioned before
we had the break.
The element is described
using four nodes.
We have the same isoparametric
coordinate system that we are
usually having.
Notice here director vector,
same description as for the
shell element that we discussed
in the earlier lecture.
Each node has 5 degrees of
freedom, 2 rotational degrees
of freedom, and 3
translational degrees of freedom.
Once again, the way we have
been discussing it in the
earlier lecture.
We use the element for analysis
of plates and for the
analysis of moderately thick
shells, and also thin shells.
And that is the important
point.
This element is directly
applicable in a very effective
manner to thin shell analysis.
The key step in the formulation
of the element is
to interpolate the geometry
and the displacement as
earlier described,
as we discussed
in the earlier lecture.
But to interpret the transverse
shear strain tensor
components separately, and
these interpolations are
selected judiciously, to tie,
then, the intensities of these
components to the values
evaluated using the
displacement interpolations.
Let's look at what I'm saying
here now pictorially.
The strain tensor interpolation
that we are
using is shown here in blue
on the black element.
These are the rt transfer
shear strain tensor
components.
This is one interpolation
function, and this is the
other interpolation function.
Notice that if we look at the
r- and s-axes, the rt strain
tensor component is constant
in r, but varies
linearly with s.
Here, too, constant in 4,
varying linearly with s.
Now it's these intensities, one
here and one there, that
we tie to the nodal point
displacements and rotations.
Here for this intensity, we
use these nodal point
descriptions, and for this
intensity, we use these nodal
point descriptions, or nodal
point degrees of freedom.
So if you recognize that these
are, it seems, unknown
quantities that enter into the
formulation since we're using
these two interpolations--
this one is an unknown quantity
that enters into the
formulation, that one is an
unknown quantity that enters
into the formulation--
if you recognize that, then you
have to ask yourself, what
do we do with these unknown
quantities?
Well, we eliminate these
unknown quantities by
expressing them in terms of
the nodal point degrees of
freedom, these two nodes here
and these two nodes.
And thus we eliminate these
tensor component intensities.
And in the K matrix and the F
vector, we end up having then
only the nodal point
displacement degrees of freedom.
And that's the key part.
For the ft transfer shear strain
tensor components, we
use these two interpolations.
Now we notice that we have a
linear description in r and
constant in s for both of
these two components.
We proceed, of course, to
eliminate this intensity and
that intensity in terms
of the nodal
point degrees of freedom.
Same way as we are
proceeding here.
This element, the MITC4 element,
has only 6 zero
eigenvalues, no spurious
zero energy modes.
It passes a patch test. And
this is a very important
point-- that the element process
the patch test. What
do we mean by the patch test?
Well, the idea in the patch
test is that any arbitrary
patch of elements should be
able to represent constant
stress conditions.
Let's see how we perform that
patch test. Here we take an
arbitrary patch of elements.
Some of the elements in that
patch of elements would be
geometrically distorted.
And we subject this patch to
the minimum displacement
rotation boundary conditions
to eliminate the physical
rigid body molds, and then
constant boundary tractions
corresponding to the
constant stress
condition that is tested.
These two items we apply to
the patch of elements, and
then we calculate
all nodal point
displacement and element stresses.
The patch test is passed if
the calculated element
internal stresses
and nodal point
displacements are correct.
In other words, let's
go through this
thought once again.
What we're doing,
really, is we're
looking at this structure.
In essence, we are taking out
of this big mesh of elements
in the structure a certain
set of elements.
We call that set of elements
a patch of elements.
We apply to this patch of
elements the minimum boundary
conditions to eliminate the
rigid body molds and traction
along the boundary that should
result in constant stress
conditions within
the elements.
If in fact, our solution for
that patch of elements gives
us constant stress conditions
and nodal point displacement
that correspond to these
constant stress conditions,
then the patch test is passed.
and this means that we would
have an element that
ultimately, as the mesh is made
finer and finer with that
element, the solution
will converge
to the correct solution.
That's the patch test, and
the most important test,
particularly for shell elements,
when we have these
complications of various kinds
of interpolations in the
element formulation,
and so on.
Well, here, schematically, I
show such patch of elements.
x1-axis, x2-axes, flat
patch of elements.
Notice the elements
not distorted,
not rectangular elements.
We take certain material
properties,
assign a certain thickness.
We make it a thin patch
of elements.
The plate that we're looking at
here is, in essence, thin.
Notice thickness 0.01, width
10 in both directions.
And so if the elements would
lock do to shear or membrane
locking, the way we discussed
earlier, we would certainly
see it by subjecting this patch
of elements to bending
moment boundary conditions.
The membrane test would
correspond to these stress
conditions.
The bending twisting test would
correspond to these
stress conditions.
These are the externally applied
forces, tractions that
the patch of element is
subjected for bending twisting
tests, here for membrane
tests.
And once again, we adjust the
rigid body modes from the
patch of elements by setting
the appropriate number of
degrees of freedom, nodal point
degrees of freedom,
equal to zero, and then subject
that patch of elements
to the tractions corresponding
to these stress conditions,
the six ones that I'm
showing here.
And we measure the internal
stresses, and find whether
these internal stresses indeed
correspond to the constant
stress situation.
Also, since only those nodal
point degrees of freedom have
been removed on the boundary
that take out the rigid body
modes, we should also see that
the other nodal point degrees
of freedom, of course, have
taken on the exact analytical
value corresponding to
the constant stress
condition that is tested.
This one, that one, that one,
or the other three here.
That's the patch test.
Well, let us now to look at some
examples regarding the
elements that we have discussed
in the previous
lecture and this lecture.
And the first example that I
like to look at with you is
the analysis of a spherical
shell with a hole.
There's a hole here, and you
see the sphere here.
Here's the backside
of the sphere,
shown by a dashed line.
And this sphere is subjected to
concentrated forces, shown
by these arrows.
Radius given here, thickness
given here, and the material
property of the sphere
given right there.
The first step is to select
director vectors.
We talked in the previous
lecture very heavily about the
fact that we use director
vectors, and we have to define
these director vectors.
The initial director vectors,
or the director vectors for
the initial configuration.
And we in fact, in this
particular case, can quite
easily generate the director
vectors for each node.
The director vector for each
node, in this particular case,
is chosen to be parallel
to the radial vector.
So if we look, this is the skin
of the shell from the
midpoint out via the radial
vector, we would see the
director vector right here
in two dimensions, of
course, x and y.
So we generate these
director vectors.
In ADINA, that can be
done automatically.
And then we would select the
boundary, displacement
boundary conditions.
If we look at what happens, for
example, in the zx phase,
using symmetry conditions, of
course we would only look at a
particular part of the shell.
The part of the shell, in fact,
maybe I should show you
that one first, that we want
to look at is shown here.
Notice here we have the part of
the shell that we analyze
because of symmetry
conditions.
We have here a symmetry
boundary and
there a symmetry boundary.
Notice that we have x, y, and z,
the coordinate system used
here, and that this part of the
shell really lies in the
part of the coordinate system
that we're looking at.
In other words, zy, y here,
z up there, xz, x
here, z comes out there.
So here we have y equal to 0 on
this face, and on this face
here, we have x equal to 0.
And what I'd like to now talk
briefly about is about the
selection of the boundary
conditions
along these two faces.
Well, these boundary conditions,
if we look at the
zx face, in other words, this
face here, we see on this view
graph here the x face--
here is the shell.
Here we would have our director
vector at time 0, and
at time t, that director vector
would have moved as
indicated by the red here.
Notice that with this movement,
the only rotation
that we can have is the
theta y rotation.
And that is now shown on
the next view graph.
Notice theta y here is free,
a free rotation.
Theta x must be 0.
Theta z must be 0.
And of course uy must be 0,
because these are material
particles, and in particular
that one there is a material
particle on the zx phase.
So uy is 0.
uz and ux are have free.
The free degrees of freedom,
once again, uz,
ux, and theta y.
Well, to impose, then, the
boundary condition, we would
proceed as shown for this
material particle along all
the nodes on this face, and
similarly, of course, on the
other face--
the face on the zy.
To prevent the rigid body
translations, we would also
have to take 1 degree of freedom
out, namely one z
degree of freedom out, one
displacement degree of freedom
corresponding to the
z-direction out.
And that then would basically
give us all the boundary
conditions that we have to
apply for this problem.
So let's look at this view graph
here to show the mesh
that we are Using.
And we show here that at this
node, we set uz equal to 0 to
prevent the rigid body motion
into this direction.
The linear elastic analysis
results for this problem are
given here.
Notice displacement at
the point of load
application is 0.0936.
The analytical value
is shown here.
Pictorially, the original mesh
is shown in black, and the
deformed mesh is shown in red.
The important point of this
problem, and I'd like to go
back to it once more, is really
that when we look at
this mesh, that we define the
director vectors at each of
these nodes--
and that can be done
automatically, they can be
generated--
that at each all of these
internal nodes, we use 5
degrees of freedom, we have two
locally aligned alpha and
beta degrees of freedom, the one
that I talked about in the
earlier lecture, at each of
these internal nodes.
I like to distinguish the
internal nodes here from the
boundary nodes.
On the boundary nodes, we of
course have also only 5
natural degrees of freedom, but
we assign now 6 degrees of
freedom there.
Meaning that the alpha and beta
degrees of freedom are
rotated into the three Cartesian
coordinate axes so
as to have three rotations at
each of these nodes on the
symmetry faces.
And then we can very easily
impose the symmetry boundary
condition that I just
talked about.
That's the important point
of this problem, really--
how we model the boundary
conditions, and what degrees
of freedom are assigned
to each of the nodes.
Well as a second example, I'd
like to consider with you the
analysis of an open box,
a 5-sided open box.
Here we show the box upside
down, or open site down.
The open side, in other
words, is down here.
And the box lies on a rigid,
frictionless surface.
On top here, we have pressure
applied to the face.
The box is modelled using
shell elements.
The point of this problem is to
discuss with you how we are
modelling this box using the
concept of director vectors, 5
degrees of freedom, 6 degrees of
freedom, that we discussed
in the earlier lecture.
So what we need to do here is
choose initial director
vectors, choose 5 or 6 degrees
of freedom for each node, and
choose the appropriate
boundary conditions.
The way we proceed there
is as follows.
We recognize that we could deal
with director vectors at
every one of the nodes, but if
we do so, at a corner, you
would have no unique
director vectors.
You could, of course, assign
there a mean normal.
In other words, if you look
closely here, my hands show
the corner, and the pointer
shows the mean
normal at that corner.
And that mean normal, mean in
quotes, would be the direction
of the director vector.
Let me show it from
up like that.
Here you have the right angle
between my hands, and you have
the pointer giving you
the director vector.
That would be one possibility.
However, if you use ADINA, then,
in this particular case,
it is more effective to not
input director vectors.
Because if you don't do so
with ADINA, then for each
node, ADINA will generate
automatically a mid-surface
normal vector.
In other words, if no director
vector has input for a node,
then ADINA generates for each
element connected to the node
a nodal point mid-surface this
normal vector at that node
from the element geometry.
Now, what does this mean?
It means that if you use this
option, there will then be as
many different nodal point
mid-surface normal vectors at
the node as there are elements
connected to the node.
Now we will have to look at
this statement much more
closely for this particular
example.
In this particular case, using
the option of automatic
generation of element nodal
point mid-surface normal
vectors, we find that at a node
away from an edge, we
will end up with just one
mid-surface normal vector.
Because see, this is a flat
surface, and the program will
calculate for this element and
that element and that element
and this element, corresponding
to that node,
the same normal vector.
And that is the normal
vector that the
program will then use.
However, if we look at an edge,
along an edge, and pick
a node there, then at this node,
there will be 1 normal
vector calculated for this
element and that element at
that node, shown by this red
arrow, and one normal vector
at this node calculated for this
element and that element,
shown by this red arrow.
Of course here, you would have
three normal vectors.
One on that phase, that
phase, and this phase.
Well, with these normal vectors,
then, given, you
recognize that there will be no
stiffness corresponding to
the rotation about this vector,
because these elements
don't carry stiffness in this
rotational degree of freedom.
We have to be careful with that,
and we have got to make
sure that we solve the problem
with this rotation, the
rotation corresponding to this
vector here or about this
vector, being deleted
in the model.
Whereas at this node here, we
assign 6 degrees of freedom to
the model, because the rotation
corresponding around
this vector will have stiffness,
around this vector
will have stiffness, and if you
think of a rotation in the
direction of that vector but
at this node, about this
direction, you will have
also stiffness.
So we need 6 degrees of freedom
being assigned at a
node that corresponds to
an edge or corner.
We have 5 degrees of freedom
to be assigned
to all other nodes.
This is once more
summarized here.
5 degrees of freedom at all
the nodes inside a face.
6 degrees of freedom along
an edge, and of
course also at a corner.
Let us look now overall at the
boundary conditions that we
have to assign to the box
in order to be able
to solve the problem.
Here we show now the
box open side up.
So this is really the side on
which the box is placed, but
we just switch the box around
so that we can more easily
look at what happens on
this boundary here.
Well, we have nodes that we
might call internal nodes
along here, nodes that
are not corner nodes.
And these nodes would have the
following boundary condition.
First of all, all the rotational
degrees of freedom
shown by this arrow,
this double arrow,
must have been deleted.
This I just discussed.
It is due to the fact that
there is no stiffness
corresponding to this rotation
at that node, because all the
elements coming into that node
don't have stiffness
corresponding to this rotational
degree of freedom.
This degree of freedom
is free.
That one is free.
This rotation is free.
That rotation is free.
This translation is
also deleted.
That is due to the fact that the
box can't move vertically.
It's placed on the
rigid surface.
If we look at a node that is a
corner node-- and let's pick a
more typical one.
Here we have one.
Then at this node, we only take
out, as you can see, the
z displacement degree
of freedom.
Because, once again,
the box lies on
the rigid flat surface.
But notice that these
rotations, all three
rotations, are left free.
They all carry stiffness the
way I already discussed it.
Also these translations
are free.
Typical corner node, another
typical corner node, the same
action as this corner node.
Now here we see something
in addition.
We see that this degree of
freedom is taken out, the same
way as over there.
But we also see that
this degree of
freedom is taken out.
This one is taken out in order
to prevent a rigid body
rotation about my
pointer here.
That's why we take
this one out.
And we take this one out and
that one out to also prevent
the rigid body rotation that I
just mentioned, and to prevent
the rigid body translation.
See, this translation has to be
taken out as well, and that
translation has to be taken out,
and this rotation has to
be taken out.
I repeat, this translation,
that translation, and that
rotation, all of those
have to be taken out.
And that is achieved by knocking
out this degree of
freedom, that one,
and that one.
So these are the boundary
conditions that we apply to
the nodes on the edges
that are lying
on the rigid surface.
If we perform now a linear
elastic static analysis of the
box with a uniform pressure
applied to the top off the
box, using our 4-node MITC4
element, here is a typical
element shown, this is
[? the measure ?]
that we use, we find that the
deformations are magnified,
quite highly magnified,
looking like that.
Very reasonable deformation.
We could not compare here
with any other solution.
But it's still a very
interesting demonstrative
example, because of the way we
are dealing with the director
vectors, which actually
we don't define.
We let the program generate
mid-surface nodal point vectors.
And because we could discuss the
use of the shell element
degrees of freedom, freedom is
the imposition of boundary
conditions, and other aspects.
This, then, brings me to the
end of what I wanted to
discuss this you related to the
view graph, and I'd like
to now share some further
experiences with you that I
documented on the slides.
So let me walk over here and let
us discuss the information
that is even on the slides.
The first slide here relates
to the analysis of a simply
supported plate under
uniform pressure.
This plate is modelled
as shown here.
We only model 1/4 of the plate
because of symmetry
conditions.
And as you can see here, n is
equal to 2 for 4 elements.
We analyze this plate and
we calculate the center
displacement, which means the
displacement at that point,
and compare that center
displacement to
the analytical solution.
Notice that in this particular
case, l/H is equal to 1000, so
it's a very thin plate.
And certainly we would get very
bad results if we had a
shear locking phenomenon in the
element that we're using.
As I pointed out earlier, the
MITC4 element does not have
any shear locking.
And as you can see now here, as
we increase N, as shown in
this axes, we get excellent
convergence behavior to the
analytical solution.
Now the next slide shows
the analysis of a
very similar plate.
Again, a square plate, l/H
still being 1,000.
Simply supported plate.
But now the plate is subjected
to a concentrated load.
And in this particular case,
we see the solution results
obtained with the MITC4 element
as a function of N--
same number N that I referred
to in the earlier slide.
We see that we get also very
good convergence behavior in
this particular case.
Not quite as good as for the
uniformly distributed pressure
case, but still very
good as well here.
The next slide shows the plate
now clamped at its edges.
Not any more simply supported.
l/H still 1,000, so still
a very thin plate.
And here we once again
calculate the center
displacement as a function
of N, the
number of elements used.
Remember, N equal 1
means 4 elements.
Remember N equals 4
means 16 elements.
Once again, we see excellent
convergence behavior to the
exact analytical solution.
And finally, this was a case
for uniform pressure.
Now we look at the case for a
concentrated load applied at
the center.
And here we see this convergence
behavior.
Of course, this is quite a
complicated, difficult problem
to analyze, because of the
concentrated load and the
clamp boundary conditions.
Here in this analysis, we used
nice square elements.
A very important consideration
in a practical analysis is to
identify how well an
element performs
when it becomes distorted.
And the next slides now relates
to that question.
Here we now model 1/4 of the
plate using mesh 1, shown
here, and using mesh
2, shown here.
Notice the elements that we're
now using in these analyses is
still the MITC4 element.
Each of these elements is an
MITC4 element, but it's a
distorted element.
And our objective is really to
identify what displacement
predictions we obtain at the
center, at point c of the
plate, when the plate is subject
to uniform pressure,
and the plate is also
simply supported.
And what displacement
predictions do we obtain for
these two measures at
these two points?
How much do they deteriorate
when compared to the usage of
nice square elements?
Well, the displacement
predictions are given here.
Finite element over Kirchhoff
theory results.
Mesh 1, 0.93, mesh 2, 1.01.
Notice mesh 2 has
just 1% error.
Mesh 1 has 7% error.
But with mesh 1, we have a very
coarse mesh, and highly
distorted elements.
It's of course also of interest
to see what moment
predictions one obtains, and
here we compare the finite
element moment versus the
Kirchhoff moment at point c.
And you can see 15% error for
mesh 1, 2% error for mesh 2.
Actually also very good
results for moment
prediction, as well.
I should also emphasize, please,
that l/H is equal to
1,000, so we are still talking
about this very thin plate.
The next slide now shows how
the element behaves in the
analysis of a skew plate.
It's also now a distorted
element mesh, or rather, the
elements used in the meshing
of this plate are distorted
elements, but they're a little
bit more regular distorted.
In fact, they are parallelogram
elements.
Notice, please, that this is a
top view, so we are seeing a
plan view of the plate.
And--
SPEAKER: Pick up lecture
20, tape B, slide
20-7, time code 20:33:18.
Take one.
PROFESSOR: The next analysis
that I like to consider now is
the analysis of the
skew plate.
Here we show a top view of the
skew plate with an angle of
skew of 30 degrees.
So it's a highly skewed plate.
And this is the kind of
mesh we want to use.
Here we show the 4-by-4 mesh
of MITC4 elements.
Notice the elements are
distorted, but sort of
regularly distorted, because
they are having a
parallelogram shape.
The boundary conditions on the
plate are simply supported
boundary conditions, which I
should point out are modelled
using the isoparametric
degenerate plate elements,
shell elements, that
we talked about.
These boundary conditions are
modelled by simply setting
only the transverse displacement
at the nodes, on
the boundary equal to 0.
In other words, the
displacements corresponding to
the z-axis, pointing out of the
slide, are set equal to 0,
but the rotations on the
boundary nodes are left free.
This is a very interesting
point, most interesting point.
And if you like to read up on
it, please refer to the
reference that is given
in the study guide
related to this slide.
Well, we use these kinds of
meshes to analyze the plate.
Notice the material data
are given here.
The thickness of the plate
is given here.
B is equal to 1, so we have a
thickness with ratio of 1/100.
It's a fairly thin plate.
And we are considering uniform
pressure applied to the plate.
The next slide now shows
analysis results.
4-by-4 mesh, 8-by-8, 16-by-16,
32-by-32 meshes were used.
We compare our finite element
solution at the point C, the
midpoint of the plate,
versus the Morley
solution at that point.
And you can see that we really
have obtained very nice
conversions to the
Morley solution.
Notice here, we're looking
at the principal moments,
actually the maximum and the
minimum moments, at that
midpoint of the plate again,
point C, and we're comparing
finite element solutions
with Morley solutions.
And here once again, quite
good convergence for the
moment, as well.
Now in this analysis, we use the
kind of mesh, this 4-by-4
mesh, that we had on
the previous slide.
And one can ask, of course, is
that a good mesh to use?
Well, we deliberately wanted
to use this mesh in this
analysis to test the capability
of the element.
Of course, one could use
a different mesh.
And on the next slide now, I'm
showing the results obtained
by using just four elements,
a 2-by-2 mesh, to
model 1/4 of the plate.
And you can see, with this
2-by-2 mesh, we get already
excellent predictions of the
displacement at the point C.
This is where point
C is, once again.
Excellent prediction of the
displacement at point C when
compared with Morley solution.
The moment is quite poorly
predicted, still.
The two moments that
I defined earlier.
If we go to a finer mesh, 4-by-4
mesh, the moments, of
course, are much better, and
so is the displacement
prediction.
But the displacement prediction
was already goods,
so there is not that much
of an improvement.
But in general, one can say,
this here, certainly for
displacement predictions, is a
much better mesh to use than
the earlier meshes that
we used for the
earlier table results.
Now I'd like to look at another
problem, the analysis
of a cantilever subjected to
an end-bending moment, and
undergoing very large
displacement.
Here are the data given
corresponding to the
cantilever, an elastic
structure that
we're looking at.
And we will be measuring v, phi,
and u, and u, v, and phi
would take on large values.
In fact, we will actually
normalize u and v to the
length of the cantilever.
The next slide now shows
the results obtained.
v/l, u/l, and phi over
2 pi as a function
of the moment applied.
We're using here moment
parameter, but of course, the
moment increases along this
axis, and here we are plotting
u/l, v/l, and phi over 2 pi.
Notice that even for very large
displacement, v/l being
0.7, with 1 cubic element, cubic
in the direction of the
cantilever, excellent results.
This is, in other words, the use
of the cubic element, in
general the 16-node
shell element, for
these types of analyses.
And it shows that the 16-node
shell element is
really quite effective.
The next slide now shows
how we would
apply the MITC4 element.
Here we use just two elements
to model the cantilever,
bending moment applied
here, clamped
boundary conditions here.
And you can see that here we
are plotting u/l, w/l, phi
over 2 pi, as before, moment
parameter along here.
And you can see that we're
getting really excellent
results just with 2 elements for
w/l 0.6, or certainly up
0.5, very close to the
analytical solution.
The analytical solution is
given by the solid line.
The next slide now shows the
result obtained using three
MITC4 elements to model
the same cantilever.
Notice these are now the nodes
that we also have used when
using the cubic element
in our first result.
And note this excellent
comparison with the analytical
solution for u/l, w/l,
and phi over 2 pi.
Very large displacement under
very large displacement
conditions.
The next slide now shows the
analysis of an I-section
clamped at this end
and subjected to a
torque at this end.
This is actually quite a
complicated problem if you
think deeper about the problem
and recognize that you have
torsional conditions, restrained
warping here,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
torsion here, then of course you
have bending in the beam,
et cetera, et cetera.
It's not a very easy
problem if you look
deeply into the problem.
And we wanted to obtain some
relatively good prediction for
this structural response when
the structure goes into the
elastoplastic regime.
Here we have the material data
used in the analysis.
You can see perfectly plastic
conditions by using tangent
material modulus equal to 0.
The slide here now shows one
model that we use, namely the
use of altogether 9
isoparametric cubic elements.
These are rectangular
elements.
Notice this is 1 isoparametric
element.
This is the mid-surface or the
neutral axis of that one
isoparametric cubic rectangular
section element.
We are modeling the whole
I-beam by assembling the
I-beam using 9 such elements.
Of course we discussed earlier
that these elements contain
the proper warping conditions.
We have supplemented our
isoparametric interpolation by
warping functions, and those
now of course will be
activated in picking up the
torsional response, or
modelling the torsional
response.
This is a free end, that's
the fixed end.
This was one model that we used,
and in addition, we used
another model, which
is shown here--
a model of shell elements,
9-node shell
elements, 9 such elements.
Of course, a better response
would have been obtained by
using the 16-node element, but
that of course would have been
a more expensive analysis.
So in this particular case, we
wanted to test this model
versus the isoparametric beam
model that I just showed you.
Notice one interesting point,
how we are modelling this
connection here.
You see a blown-up
figure of it.
At this point node c, we have
just 5 degrees of freedom.
No rotational stiffness about
this vector here.
So that is not a degree
of freedom.
Here we have 6 degrees of
freedom, 3 translational
degrees of freedom and 3
rotational degrees of freedom.
Here we have 5 degrees
of freedom.
No degree of freedom, no
stiffness corresponding to the
rotation about this
vector here.
That's one of the important
points that we discussed
earlier already.
Well, to proceed with the
analysis, we actually use the
longitudinal element dimensions
shown here.
Notice that we use a shorter
element at the fixed end than
here at the free end, because we
anticipate heavy plasticity
here that we wanted to model
quite accurately.
Once again, the torque is
applied here, and theta x is
measured here.
And on the next slide now, we
show the variation of the
torque as a function of
the theta x [? rate ?]
rotation.
Notice here you have the isobeam
model solution, and
here you have the shell
model solution.
We compare our results with
a sand heap solution and a
Merchant's upper
bound solution.
These are simplified analytical
solutions to this problem.
Our results here are somewhat
close, but not very close.
Of course, one could make a
much deeper study of this
problem, a very interesting
problem.
But the way we now already have
concluded our study and
the way I show you the results,
see, I think it's
already quite valuable, because
we have learned a bit
regarding the modeling of
this type of problem.
Well, the next slide now shows
a final problem for which I
wanted to show you some
solution results.
Here we have a cylindrical
shell supported on rigid
diaphragms at the end,
and the shell is
subjected to uniform pressure.
We measure here wB, the
displacement at that
particular point B. The data
corresponding to the shell are
given here.
Notice that we model the shell
as an elastic, perfectly
plastic material, and notice
that in the shell, we modeled
only this part of the shell,
this quarter part of the
shell, using a 9-by-9
uniform mesh of the
4-node MITC4 element.
The results are now given
on the slide shown here.
Pressure applied plotted along
this axis, wB plotted along
this axis, and this is a
non-linear solution response
we have obtained using the MITC4
element, and we compare
our solution with the solution
given by Krakeland.
I might point out that in this
analysis, we used our
automatic load-stepping scheme
that we discussed when we
talked about the solution of the
non-linear finite element
equations in an earlier
lecture.
Very good comparison
up to this point
with Krakeland's solution.
We did not go much further
than that solution given,
because we could not
compare with any
other solution anyway.
Well, this brings me now to the
end of what I wanted to
discuss with you regarding
shell elements.
Of course, please remember
there is a lot more
information that we could have
discussed and that we could
have studied together, but we
only have two lectures, and
this is the information that I
wanted to share with you in
these two lectures.
I hope you enjoyed it.
Please also refer to the papers
that are given as
references for these two
lectures, particularly for the
slides, where you will find much
more information, many
more details regarding this
material that we discussed.
Thank you very much for
your attention.